genug gelacht jetzt reden wir mal über
den Iran wo sich gerade immer mehr
Menschen auf die Straße trauen gegen das
Regime der Mullahs ja und das trotz
hemmungsloser und immer hemmungsloser
staatlicher Gewalt Auslöser der Proteste
wissen Sie sicher bei der Tod der
22-jährigen Studentin masseamini die im
Gewahrsam der sogenannten Sittenpolizei
gestorben ist nachdem man sie für ein
verrutschtes Kopftuch verhaftet hatte
das klingt für uns hier erstmal völlig
krank ist aber im Iran leider Alltag
Mann
bekannter iranischer Schlager im Wagen
vor mir bremst ein dummes Arschloch
hut ab beziehungsweise Kopftuch ab für
diese mutige Frau klar gibt es Frauen
die das freiwillig tragen sollte man
respektieren aber natürlich ist das
Kopftuch ein Symbol für soziale
Kontrolle für all die geh- und Verbote
dem Iran exklusiv für Doppel x
chromosomenträgerinnen gelten ist ja so
in einem Land in einem Land mit bitterer
Armut und durch und durch korrupten
Eliten die ihre eigenen Kinder übrigens
auf Unis im Westen schicken während sie
die Studenten zu Hause verprügeln oder
erschießen lassen die sogenannte
Islamische Republik ist nicht nur keine
Republik sie ist ein einziges XXL
Gefängnis ausgeplündert von Verbrechern
sehr viel Iranerinnen haben illegal
Satellitenschüssel auf dem Dach das
Regime macht oft nichts manchmal räumen
sie wieder ein übrigens um sie selber
wieder zu verkaufen und Geld zu
verdienen ja da die Redewendung deine
Mutter klaut Satellitenschüssel
der Kopftuchzwang ist ein
Unterdrückungsinstrument und beleidigt
übrigens auch Männer denen ja
unterstellt wird sie würden quasi zum
Tier wenn sie Haare sehen die Herren
Mullahs sollten sich mal fragen wie sie
das finden wenn sie irgendwer zwingen
würde sich absurden Kleidervorschriften
zu unterwerfen wenn es plötzlich heißen
würde Gott will dass ihr alle Baggy
Pants tragt
umgedrehte Basecaps und viel zu kurze
Tanktops mit Bauchnabelpiercing plus
ganz schlimme Horst Lichter Schnurrbärte
wie findet ihr das na wie würdet ihr
euch da fühlen übrigens sehr erstaunlich
wie reich man mit religiösen Fanatismus
werden kann im Iran allein euer toller
harmonet der religiöse Führer
kontrolliert ein Immobilienfonds der
schon 2013 unglaubliche 95 Milliarden
Dollar wert war nicht zuletzt dank
Zwangsenteignung will sagen wir reden
hier von einer religiös überlackierten
Kleptokratie auch deshalb wird trotz der
großen Gefahr der Duft der Demonstranten
nach einem Regimewechsel immer lauter
das musste auch revolutions- beim Blick
auf sein instagram-konto erfahren unter
dem Hashtag machsaamini eine Flut
wütende Einträge
Moment der Eier toller ist bei insta ja
wirklich wahr ist einer der wichtigsten
islamfluencer überhaupt und wenn man
sich seinen Account anguckt sieht man
der hat privat auch mal eine fröhliche
Seite hier fährt er zum Beispiel auf
einem E-Scooter ins Büro hier hat der
tierisch Spaß im Phantasialand heran und
das ist am neulich auf dem Andrea Berg
Konzert da ist er voll abgegangen wie
man sieht ja ist aber erstaunlich dass
er dahin geht denn im Iran gibt es ja
auch ein leider kein Witz gesangsverbot
für Frauen frauen dürfen in der
Öffentlichkeit nicht singen weil
frag nicht irgendwas mit Gott keine
Ahnung die Ereignisse im Iran die sind
auch der erste echte Realitätscheck für
Annalena baerbock und ihre feministische
Außenpolitik im Bundestag hat die
Außenministerin neulich gesagt ich
zitiere wir sehen und hören die Frauen
im Iran ja das ist
besser als nichts ne hören und sehen
zwar hat die Ampel mehrere Tage
gebraucht um sich überhaupt mal zum
Thema zu äußern aber jetzt so heißt es
bemüht man sich um europäische
Sanktionen die Bundesregierung hat die
iranische Regierung aufgefordert die
Todesumstände der jungen Frau die durch
die Sittenpolizei festgenommen worden
war lückenlos aufzuklären
genau Aufklärung durch eine Diktatur die
seit 40 Jahren ununterbrochen lügt ich
habe ein gutes Gefühl meine Damen und
Herren dabei hätte Deutschland durchaus
einen Hebel denn wir sind Irans größter
eu-handelspartner sie merken schon dass
mit der berühmten wertebasierten Ampel
Außenpolitik läuft bisher nur so mittel
Deutschland liefert jetzt sogar aktuelle
Meldungen wieder Waffen an Saudi-Arabien
und wir schicken eben doch
Regierungsvertreter zur Fußball-WM in
Katar herzlich willkommen sport
das aktuelle werteorientierte
feministische außenpolitikstudio mit
Valerie Niehaus und Christian iron
[Musik]
hallo
das aktuelle wer orientierte
feministische Außenpolitik
Studio wir müssen dringend an unserem
Titel Arbeiten
riesen Vorfreude auf die WM in Katar
lieber Sportfans Nancy Phaser und
vielleicht sogar der Kanzler werden nun
doch persönlich dabei sein wenn unsere
Nationalmannschaft nach der Vorrunde
rausfliegt
unglaublich selbst immer mehr
sportkneipen also Leute die davon leben
werden das Turnier boykottieren aber die
Ampel schickt ihre Promis hin da fällt
mir ein was ist eigentlich mit dem ZDF
könnte unser Sender nicht auch mal
drüber nachdenken AUA der Christian
Olaf Scholz wurde gerade gefragt ob er
hinfährt und glasklarer kann eine
Antwort gar nicht ausfallen und die
Frage wie wir dahin fahren ist
selbstverständlich
zeitnah zu entscheiden aber das wird
schon so sein dass da jemand dabei ist
ich könnte zeitnah kotzen
irgendjemand ist vielleicht dabei das
könnte jeder sein mein Gott ja der Emir
hat halt nachdrücklich eingeladen nicht
im Sinne von alter wenn du Gas willst
kommst du besser vorbei
hören Sie bitte aus Katar zu kritisieren
sonst ruft ihr gleich Uli Hoeneß an wie
neulich im Doppelpass ja der guckt alles
der ist arbeitslos
gut wir brauchen Gas geschenkt bzw nicht
geschenkt teuer gekauft aber dann lasst
uns doch wenigstens die schmalzigen
Werte Passagen aus dem Koalitionsvertrag
streichen die Ampel verkauft jetzt sogar
wieder Waffen an Saudi-Arabien um
Himmels willen ja sehen Sie das doch mal
sportlich es findet halt gerade ein
Rennen statt ja welcher westliche
Staatsmann sich als erster wieder
zurückschleimt bei Prinz bin Salman
und da holt macron den ersten Platz der
Franzose ist sich von nichts zu fies
platz 2 geht an diesen englischen
Patienten Bronze für Joe beiden cooler
fistbump Untergang und da oh nein Olaf
Scholz kommt als Letzter in Riad
angebuckelt beschämender Platz das Spiel
ist aus
naja wir schicken den Audi ist immerhin
Ausrüstung und Munition für Kampfjets
und diese Nachricht kommt genau in der
Woche in der die Waffenruhe im Jemen
endet wo die Saudis Krieg führen ja
tschuldigung während einer Waffenruhe
Waffen liefern hätte ja auch gar keinen
Sinn gemacht und kaschocki ist vergessen
oder was meine Fresse was kommt denn als
nächstes Winterspiele in Saudi-Arabien
das umstrittene Milliardenprojekt ist
nun abgesegnet Saudi-Arabien erhält den
Zuschlag für die Asian Winter Games 2029
das bisher schneefreie Trojaner wäre das
erste Wintersportgebiet auf der
arabischen Halbinsel
meldung vom Dienstag
Scheiße die Regie sagt mir gerade ohne
höhnes ist in der Leitung Mensch ich
habe sie gewarnt alles ist auch klar den
Arbeitern gegen Katar geht es durch
diese im besser und die schlechten und
es sollte man endlich mal akzeptieren
und nicht stellen sie in ständig auf die
Leute drauf hauen wir gehen einfach so
dadurch
[Applaus]
nein ich mache hier gar nichts mehr
bevor ihr nicht den Kanal abonniert und
ein Like da lasst
ich habe die Schnauze voll
ja los lass ein Abo da